so we have these two or reaction we have
this one expression here that we need to
add it so it's 4x squared Y minus 3x
squared minus 2i plus 8x Y minus 3x
squared plus 2x squared y plus 4 let me
rewrite it and since we're adding this
second expression right here in
parentheses we can actually get rid of
those parentheses we can essentially
distribute that positive sign so we get
4x squared Y minus 3 x squared minus 2y
plus 8x Y minus 3x squared plus 2x
squared y plus 4 and now to simplify
this and the only reason why I could
just remove those parentheses that had a
positive right over here if this was a
negative sign then I would have to
distribute the negative in order to
remove the parentheses but with that out
of the way let's try to simplify this
and to simplify this I want to
essentially add terms that have the same
that had the same order or if they have
multiple variables have the same
variables in this at the same order of
raised to the same exponents so here I
have 4x squared Y so do I have any other
x squared Y terms so this right over
here is another x squared Y term so I
can add 4x squared wise plus 2 more x
squared wise and I will get 6x squared Y
now let's go to this x squared term
right over here do I have any other x
squared terms well I have this one right
over here
another negative 3x squared so if I have
negative 3x squared minus 3x squared
that's going to be negative 6x squared
and then I have this let me do it in
orange I have this first-degree y term
it looks like it's the only one so then
I'll just rewrite it minus 2y and then
this looks like the only X Y term right
over here so I'll just rewrite it plus
8xy and then finally I have the plus 4 I
have the plus 4 and it looks like this
is done 6x squared minus 6x squared
minus 2y plus 8 X Y
plus four